llegó la hora de la información de por
ti de la información económica en france
24 discúlpeme usted es por ello nos
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
jorge hurtado usted jorge bienvenido el
impacto de la guerra en ucrania continúa
afectando a muchas economías del mundo
así es bueno siempre vamos con deportes
pero antes vamos a dar los datos
económicos para ser exactos valentina
del 86 por ciento del producto interno
bruto mundial va a ser afectado por esta
guerra en ucrania según el fondo
monetario internacional así lo dijo
kristalina georgieva y el directora
gerente del fondo monetario
internacional aseguró que el organismo
que dirige rebajó las previsiones de
crecimiento de 143 países por los
efectos de la invasión rusa de ucrania
la funcionaria alertó que el futuro de
la economía es extraordinariamente
incierto por la guerra las sanciones y
la pandemia que aún golpea grandes
economías como por ejemplo china entre
los riesgos los economistas y toda la
elevadísima inflación y la fragmentación
de las economías del mundo en dos
bloques geopolíticos uno lo que llaman
las democracias y lo que ella también
denomina regímenes autoritarios
escuchemos
webber y cabra de la recuperación
mundial ya estaba perdiendo impulso
antes de la guerra de ucrania en parte
por las perturbaciones relacionadas con
omicron en enero recortamos nuestra
previsión de crecimiento mundial al 4 4%
para 2022 desde entonces las
perspectivas se han deteriorado
sustancialmente en gran medida por la
guerra y sus repercusiones
harder indicó the work in its
repercursión jorge y vladimir putin
alertó hoy de las consecuencias de
sancionar los hidrocarburos rusos
esta reacción valentina se da durante un
debate en europa sobre un posible
embargo a los suministros de petróleo y
gas rusos esto dispara los precios del
petróleo y movió los mercados globales
hoy según putin los intentos de
occidente de reemplazar la energía rusa
afectarán a toda la economía mundial
rusia suministra alrededor del 40 por
ciento del gas que consume europa y
putin advirtió que de bloquearlo
vendería la energía en asia escuchamos
los países europeos hablan
constantemente de rechazar los
suministros rusos de energía lo que
desestabiliza aún más el mercado y hace
subirlos por su propia cuenta
necesitamos diversificar las
exportaciones partiremos del hecho de
que en el futuro previsible se reducirá
el suministro de recursos energéticos en
dirección occidental por lo tanto es
importante consolidar la tendencia de
los últimos años
paso a paso cambiar la dirección de
nuestras exportaciones a los mercados de
rápido crecimiento del sur y el estudio
post jorge hasta 2020 jeff bezos era el
hombre más rico del mundo pero en 2021
esto cambió y se convirtió hilo en mosca
en el de la fortuna más grande y ahora
hizo una oferta para adquirir twitter en
sólo 10 días el hongos pasó de ser un
famoso twittero a y crítico también de
esta red social a convertirse en el
mayor accionista individual y ahora en
el posible propietario de la plataforma
nos aseguró que tiene un plan b en caso
de que la junta directiva rechace su
oferta valorada en 43.000 millones de
dólares veamos el siguiente reporte que
he preparado dennis herrera
una verdad de compra calificada de
profundamente hostil y lo más que el
hombre más rico del mundo ofreció este
jueves 43 mil millones de dólares para
comprar twitter con el fin de liberar su
extraordinario potencial twitter dijo
que revisaría cuidadosamente lo que
llamó una oferta no solicitada y no
vinculante más que dijo que su precio de
54 20 dólares por acción era su mejor y
última oferta y es generoso un 38% más
que el cierre de twitter el primero de
abril sus más esto es más en el estilo
de incluso el corporativo que busca
poseer twitter y creemos que después de
muchos giros entre idas y vueltas en
esta telenovela al final terminará
siendo dueño de twitter si la junta
directiva de seno como fiduciaria se
comerán las demandas para desayunar fuse
bosque hizo pública la semana pasada una
compra de 73.5 millones de acciones lo
que sitúa su participación en el 92 por
ciento y le abre las puertas dentro del
consejo de administración de la empresa
pero el lunes el director general de
twitter anunció que el multimillonario
se había retirado inesperadamente dos
días después de que el nombramiento se
hiciera efectivo más que se describe
como un defensor la libertad de
expresión ha criticado abiertamente a
twitter a pesar de su patrimonio neto de
219 mil millones de dólares se ha
cuestionado su capacidad para hacerse
cargo del gigante de las redes sociales
con la mayor parte de su riqueza ligada
a su empresa de autos eléctricos tesla
jorge a usted muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica ustedes gracias por
su sintonía continúan con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]